for today's classic interview I'm
actually going to refuse to give you
much of an introduction to it other than
to tell you we did not agree on policy
when I spoke to Charles Butler and he
believed that I was a girly man an
assertion that was unusual at least as
far as interviews are concerned let's
get to my interview from December of
2014 with Charles Butler this week's
classic interview I'm joined today by
Charles Butler he is a nationally
syndicated talk show host also a
financial adviser Charles it's really
great to have you on I've been listening
to your program I listened to the
December 11th show that show was a doozy
you were responding to the Senate
torture report you had a lot to say and
one thing that caught my ear and and
that's kind of where I want to start
today is you thought that Senator Dianne
Feinstein from California should be
punched why why did you come to that
conclusion well you know she heard the
only reason that she released that port
that report was for political reasons
and unfortunately David we have too many
people who are grandstanding and playing
with people's lives
she has endangered the lives of real
citizens of real patriots dr. Mitchell
said he's received death threats you
know these people do not play we know
that al-qaeda Osama bin Laden and his
life the Taliban they are killing
Americans these people are receiving
death threats because of her
unclassified information and that's why
the CIA has always sought to hide
information from Congress because of
people like Dianne funds so you're
saying you're okay with the report that
said that the CIA was lying about the
extent to which they were using these
techniques because you think it's the
right thing to do to hide that no I
don't think it's the right thing to do
to hide that but I don't think it's
anyone's business outside of it's
classified information what we do and
the facts are talking to all the people
who were involved in on the CIA side is
that they briefed Congress they briefed
Feinstein they briefed Rockefeller they
briefed all these Democrats and
Republicans also said that they were
briefed so Feinstein and the Democrats
are blatantly lied
so you said that Dianne Feinstein should
be punched what other circumstances do
you advocate physical violence against
women I don't you know I don't make that
distinction about women and in violence
see that's kind of a European you know
chivalry thing and at the end of the day
it's BS because women are out here
fighting men you see it you see it in
the movies today where women are
attacking men and like that video with
Ray Rice his wife clearly came back
across the elevator with her fist balled
up and he had a reaction he didn't punch
it once or twice he just just stuck out
his fist and jab to keep alright but so
but without getting on to that you so
you're comfortable in other words
advocating physical violence against
Dianne Feinstein who happens to be a
woman I don't care who she is if if
she's in the kitchen and she needs to
play the game and at the end of the day
what Dianne Feinstein's done a punches
is the minimum that should happen to her
but this woman because she's a senator
she has said she wants to she well she's
going to get people killed
so when you compare a punch to getting
people killed David you know you can
play that game oh it's no game I'm just
trying to figure out what your level of
comfort is advocating for violence my
level of comfort is simply this it's not
advocating he putting words in my mouth
I'm not advocating anything well I say
she should be punched presumably someone
should do the punch to right her face
yep they put these women they put these
women in positions of responsibility and
and of power and what does she do she's
playing games with peoples live yes you
use that term these women and I know
you've said we should actually have
fewer women in the Senate so why is why
should we have fewer women and just so
the audience knows women make up
slightly more than 50% of the population
they make up 20% of the Senate you think
there's too many women in the Senate why
is what now let me ask you this now
Charles before you go into that let me
just make sure my question is clear you
just said you don't make recommendations
or
statements based on gender in other
words you don't care whether you're
saying a woman or man deserves to be
punched you don't care about gender but
at the same time you're saying there
should be fewer women in the Senate so
you are actually concerned with gender
yeah that's because Dianne Feinstein if
you look at if you go back when do your
research David which I'm sure you'll do
Dianne Feinstein came out this summer
and said that we need more women in the
Senate because we're more collegiate oh
we get along we get things done that was
Diane Feinstein who say that not Charles
Butler well but there are there are
actual studies that show that women do
have a tendency to build rapport and
work together and and that that's
actually based in science though this
country in the world has worked
perfectly well with men doing what they
need to do and working together and
there's no other there's no other place
than the military that I look at where
men get together work very effectively
together in an all-male environment
without the female influence so well you
discount those studies don't Lee okay
and on what basis have you decided how
when you see that how do you decide when
a study is valid and when it isn't is it
just based on your preconceived notions
no because of the people because of the
people doing the studies when you have
these girly men who are sitting back
doing studies like well we need women on
the football field and we need women
doing this and we we don't need women
doing anything is there their
environments where that whole male
camaraderie is really important just
like let me let me just say this since
you put on their track please I I detest
the fact that women think that they can
get together and exclude men but
whenever we have an exclusive group it
needs to be feminized we need to have
submit some females in an all-male group
and you know I don't believe that we
should there are times we should have
all-male groups all-female groups I'm
for separate education for women it's
studies have shown that women who were
in all-girl environments do better in
science and math than weather study is
wet which studies are those those are
studies they're out they just like the
studies you look
Golub dosa shows a surcharge by the
government they're done by universities
and those studies have said the same
thing that girls do better in science
when they're in all-girl environments
okay so it's you we're gonna get back to
you want fewer women in the Senate but
you also have a problem with girly men
how to do studies what does that mean
though how who's a girly man well you
know there are a lot of there are a lot
of feminine males out here a David and
so you want to try to put words in my
mouth and I want to allow you to do that
well hold on a second hold on a second
but Charles that use you use the term we
don't need girly men doing Studies and I
simply I simply repeated that back to
you so what was it I put in your mouth
you try to sit I advocate I did not use
that word let me be very clear please I
am NOT I do not advocate for [ __ ] men
or men like Barack Obama in leadership
positions or men like a Boehner in
leadership positions men who obviously
have not served in the military have not
proven themselves as their male but I
they men how can they make hard you said
you say the answer has been absolutely
not okay so but this this is really the
meat of it and I hope you'll indulge me
in this when you talk about a [ __ ] man
we heard one characteristic which is
they have not served in the military how
else does Charles Butler define a [ __ ]
man I define a [ __ ] man by a guy who
saw a guy who has no commitment a guy
who who in many ways hasn't done
anything in his life but sit back and
push paper and sit behind a desk okay so
let me get let me that's very good so
Charles an accountant or lawyer who
never served in the military by your
definition that's a [ __ ] man right
no no they're they're actions that have
to be involved there are accountants and
they are lawyers who are warriors who
believe in fighting you look at and
people like Thurgood Marshall he never
served in the military he was certainly
a warrior you look at Charles Houston he
was certainly a warrior
but they fall under the definition you
just gave me for what a [ __ ] man is
they have not served in the military and
they push papers well that's included in
that definition so we're expanding that
definition let's do it but you can't so
that you can't that's we're gonna we're
gonna you know jocular here we gotta go
you know Jackie Jimmy here I'm just
going to expand that definition please
so what else is included in the
definition there's pushing paper and not
being in the military what else do we
have number things if you don't know
what a girly man is then you know Arnold
Schwarzenegger was very clear about
girly men wasn't he yes but but teach me
I'm too low that would be my definition
the Arnold Schwarzenegger definition of
girly man that would be my definition
okay I'm getting the sense you don't
really know what that definition was but
means because see there they are girlie
men out here yeah they're sissies and
and they're males but they're certainly
not men okay so you agree all right
that's fine perfect so let's go back to
the women in the Senate twenty women in
the Senate out of a hundred slightly
more than 50% of the population is made
up of women you are fewer women in the
Senate why right like Dianne Feinstein
because your collegiate Co and they
don't understand and Barbara Boxer and I
can go down the list Elizabeth Warren
yeah people who don't understand what
this country needs in order to move
forward here you but then Charles
question for you and I asked this
completely honestly if you first said
you don't care about gender women men if
they don't like hold on a second let me
let me get the question out and then if
you disagree with the framing of it
you'll I'll allow you to tell me you
first said you don't use gender as a
basis on which to analyze whether
someone should or shouldn't have
something happen to them etc no but hold
on Charles hold on judge please let me
just get the question out okay you were
talking about Feinstein yeah yeah then
you said you would like to see fewer
women in the Senate but when I asked you
why you want fewer women
the Senate you gave a definition that
could apply to men or women in other
words the way and so there's why is it
that you want fewer women in this
because the women that I have seen
American women in this who enter
politics yes especially the American
women that we have in politics today
like Hillary Clinton you know they don't
quite measure up you notice how they
don't quite measure up to the foreign
women like Golda Meir they don't measure
up to to Maggie Thatcher or even Andrea
Merkel have you noticed that I have not
no I haven't noticed but but what did
Hillary Clinton want to do the first
thing she said was all the guys are
picking on me see American women this is
gets back to my initial point why I
don't differentiate between punching a
girl or punching a guy yeah you know
people put themselves in that position
and I think that you have to deal with
whatever position comes along because in
my culture women will kick your behind
now where you say your culture what do
you what is that what is your culture
black women will fight you they will
fight you like a man and if you don't
fight back if you don't defend yourself
you're going to get will and people mean
we laugh about it all the time like
everybody this whole Ray Rice thing I
was listening to Marshall Faulk at a
golf outing that he played and he played
our force and we won the tournament by
the way but he was very clear about how
he felt that Ray Rice was being
railroaded he was he's been denigrated
his wife even said well I attacked him
which she did but you know the white
media the white girlie media with these
all these girls well he punched her out
he didn't go over and attack her he
didn't jump on her when she was pushing
the button he he hit her she responded
she came across the you know that's
interesting so what you're saying is
that you feel that there are specific
characteristics to what you've called as
your culture black culture which with
regard to the Ray Rice
janay rice domestic violence situation
right media didn't portray that taking
into consideration and understand a
better understanding of black cultures
that way
saying I'm saying that exactly and the
bottom line is black women will punch
you out they will fight that's in the
black culture and people know that we
know that we have limited time to
Terrell what very few white women will
engage you and punch or try to fight you
it's a totally different culture and
then and then when this witness uh the
NFL do they go higher for white women to
deal with the league that's 75 percent
black totally crazy it along the same
lines that having only twenty percent of
women in the Senate when half the
population as women is right I mean it's
the same thing we have a lack of
representation what I care about I don't
care about the population see that's a
girlie man you just watch Aras Charles
you just talked about the population you
said the population of the NFL is
seventy five percent women David they're
twenty percent blacks in the population
is anybody talking about the Senate
needs to be twenty percent black they
certainly should why shouldn't we have
what why don't we have why don't we have
a governing body that is representative
more or less of the population at large
it's not is I talk about that all the
time that's not I don't know what
happens on your show by the way when we
start talking about white women and
income disparity that's who they're
talking about they're not talking about
black women income disparity because
black women make less than white women
in the in the in the workplace I don't
know who I don't know who they is but I
talk about racial income disparities
okay hey I want to talk about something
else from your December 11th show and
this is a really serious thing you said
the lefties need to leave and they need
to experience Sharia law now this is a
really serious thing and I'm gonna allow
you to respond to this but just hear me
out because it's the American right the
American Christian Right whose positions
mirror those of Sharia law and I'll tell
you why and I know you won't agree and
I'll let you respond subjugation of
women homophobia anti-science xenophobia
willingness to go to violence very
quickly to achieve political goals which
themselves are informed by religion
wanting a theocratic government where
religion informs the law the line and
even the Pope has admitted this the line
between Sharia law and American
extremist right-wing Christians is a
pretty direct line isn't it Charles I
don't hear it's not everything that you
say it is absolutely false go point by
point hold on go point by point which of
the points well I don't have your notes
but if you emailed them over that I'd
have your notes to go by okay but hold
on Charles we can we can result you and
I can resolve this very very simply the
Sharia lies anti-gay and American
extremist Christians aren't is your
business I don't put it in my face and
it will never be it will never be
acceptable to me okay we're God so you
will but Sir Charles the Pope can't make
up Scripture so I don't care about this
Pope who forget the Pope okay but so you
agree but Charles let's this isn't
really important let's go piece by piece
the Pope okay you say the Pope may be a
homo that's fine let's go step by step
though so on the on the gay issue you
agree that Sharia and right-wing
Christians have the same view on that
one you do a group no I'm not agreeing
to that you just did though you said
yeah I'm anti gay Christians are
anti-gay you're drawing that connection
what I say it is that scripture says
that homosexuality is not is not is
immoral and that's that's my morality
okay so the scripture agrees the
scripture agrees okay the scripture
agrees with Sharia law those who agree
with Sharia law the scripture is the
scripture Christian scripture okay duis
rila Sharia law uses religion to inform
what is the judicial system in the same
way that American right-wing Christians
based on their scribbles hold on
Charlotte Charles hold on you got to let
me get the questions out though you've
got to let me get the question out in
the same way that Sharia law is Muslim
Scripture
the judicial system American right-wing
Christians want to use their scripture
to inform the judicial system for
example homosexuality being illegal
abortion being illegal the teaching of
creationism in public school so that's
another similarity right no you you know
what you do is mix apples and oranges no
but I'm not gonna allow you to sit here
and because judeo-christian law it
doesn't believe in homosexuality
nor does Buddha with Buddhism or
Hinduism
they all are anti-gay if that's what you
want to call it okay but I'm off that
point already I'm on the the use of
scripture to inform the law obviously
you have a pro liberal Pro gay agenda
that's fine but I'm not gonna allow you
to sit here
well the right way I'm not a right
winger okay but but if you're going to
say that what I'm saying is wrong if
you're not going to allow me then you
should explain to me why I'm wrong
rather than just saying you don't agree
well the thing that you've done and that
you that you've done is you want to have
talking points if you want to talk about
politics you want to talk about these
issues I don't have your talking points
in front of me so but we're deciding a
conversation there are no talking points
per se because obviously you know but
Charles the top one point stupid
Americans you talk to David Charles is
about back I was doing this long before
you were born problem so I don't know
what's that else to do with it though
the talking point is by what you say on
your show is that you sit here and you
try to put words and put your inflection
on what I said and what I mean I think
if anybody simply this and what I mean
is simply this there is no comparison in
my opinion right the right-wing
extremism and and and and Sharia law
okay that's fine I would I would have
loved it Charles and we are a time I
would have loved it if you had given us
data as to why they're different as
opposed to just saying you won't allow
me to connect it you would give it all
you have to do is
google it yeah and if you given me the
the talking point we were going to have
the topics I would have provided you
with the links that you could have gone
no but I think I think there's a
misunderstanding goes like that thing
about girls who girls who were in
all-girls environment do better in
sciences and math you should know that
no right right right no and you should
know about
but Charles I think the misunderstanding
is as we wrap up that you are acting as
if I kind of set the agenda but I merely
listen to one of your shows and talked
about things you had already discussed
so I may have been mistaken but I
thought that because these were your
topics from your show they would be fair
game well so you know I'm very
comfortable with I said yes I would if I
had been on the city floor I would punch
Diane Feinstein's you see the Americans
that she exposed to to to be harassed
and to be threatened with death threats
yes she needs to pay there is something
that needs to happen to her she needs to
be indicted and they fight say they used
to fight in the Senate in the old Senate
and in the old Congress when guys with
it and how about Bush and Cheney they
should be indicted too right well no I
don't think so
okay they say you think so because you
have that liberal agenda so you know
you've got a that girly-man click I get
it but do you do you not think so
because you have a right-wing agenda in
other words the same allegation of bias
could exist right we should talk about I
don't think so because what made all the
things that they did first of all we're
legal and all the things they did were
in the best interests of the company the
country
hold on Charles Charles Kelly how are
they Charles how are they in the best
interest of the country when the report
made clear that they did not work there
was no that's not true it did work the
report is like the reporters report
alive you you know you you got that
left-wing thing going you know with the
you know no no Republicans were asked no
CIA people were asked about this report
and like Gruber said most Americans are
pretty stupid Charles but Charles
Charles Charles can you say
Charles how can you say that the report
did not involve the CIA when it was hold
on Charles I got to get the question the
CIA are the the ones who admitted that
the techniques did not work so how can
you say the CIA was not involved that's
a lie that's a lie
you're lying they did admit that it
worked good that Rodriguez admitted that
they worked and we got information from
police Sheikh Mohammed that all was
initially safe dr. dr. Mitchell said
that we got information from Khalid
Sheikh Mohammed also but we now know
that that's not true we now know what
that I don't know what books you read or
what who's to give you your information
the Senate torture report it's not a toy
by the way waterboarding is not torture
young man we thought it was we thought
it was when the Japanese did it to us in
World War two but we didn't think it was
torture with is that torture they were
prosecuted for torture yeah they were
that's not true liberals you like the
life I know I'm just a girly man liberal
I know all right I'm gonna try whoa I'm
just a girly man liberal I'm sorry i
whatever comes to your hometown David
you will know that when these terrorists
and the illegals yeah your neighborhood
okay
well all right I I apologize that I'm
just a girly man with no gonna all right
we've been speaking with Charles Butler
nationally syndicated talk show host
he's a fascinating man we can certainly
agree on that Charles a pleasure having
you thank you so much for being on